son víctimas del impacto de la
contaminación en ese hospital pediátrico
de nueva delhi denuncian que las
afectaciones respiratorias se han
triplicado entre los últimos 7 y 10 días
esto está directamente relacionado con
los altos niveles de contaminación de
los que estamos siendo testigos en la
ciudad de delhi y en la región capital
nacional
durante las últimas jornadas el índice
de calidad de aire de la ciudad ha
estado por encima de 451 en una escala
de 500 algo que se traduce en una
situación grave por una orden de la
comisión de la ciudad para la calidad
del aire se extendió de manera
indefinida al cierre de las escuelas así
como la suspensión en al menos cinco de
las 11 fábricas que funcionan con carbón
también se prohibió el tránsito de los
camiones que no sean esenciales además
se dio la orden de enviar a teletrabajo
a la mitad de los funcionarios medidas
que cuestionan algunos expertos en las
medidas de emergencia aunque sean muy
drásticas no son medidas fáciles y
convenientes para aplicar
se hacen solamente para asegurar que la
situación no empeore what's the switch
esta polución impulsada sobre todo por
la contaminación industrial la quema de
cultivos estacional y la bajada de las
temperaturas es regional la vecina
ciudad del ajo en pakistán también vive
una crisis ambiental por estas fechas
con niveles de partículas de
contaminación 8 veces superiores a lo
recomendado en delhi ya hay una amenaza
de confinamiento por contaminación a
pedido de la corte suprema del país